Hallo, Erwild ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie Ihre Fragen jederzeit stellen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Walter Kaufmann.
Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamenbuch stabilen?
Ja, Walter schreibt sich W-A-L-T-E-R Walter und Kaufmann-K-A-U-F-M-A-N-N.
Kaufmann.
Ja, also Herr Kaufmann, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 64.
65. Wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 26. März 1961.
61.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,83 m groß und 680 kg schwer.
680 kg schwer und wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Lindemann.
Dr. Lindemann.
Alles klar.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen ziemlich starke Schmerzen im linken Bein.
Ab der Mitte vom Oberschenkel ungefähr ab.
Bis in den Unterschenkel rein und in den Fuß.
Habe ich Schmerzen?
Können Sie das wieder beschreiben?
Weil ich Notizen mache.
Wo der Schmerz ist?
Genau.
Ab der Mitte vom Oberschenkel ungefähr.
Nicht ganz zu Beginn, sondern ab der Mitte.
Und im Unterschenkel und bis in den Fuß hinein.
Bis in den Fuß, ja.
Und da vorne oder?
Sonst habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Ich hatte Schmerzen schon mal im linken Bein.
Seit einigen Wochen merkte ich, wenn ich beim Gehen nach 150-200 m bekam,
ich Schmerzen im Bein, besonders im Unterschenkel.
Und da musste ich auch mal stehen bleiben, Pause machen.
Ja, das war seit einigen Wochen.
Aber jetzt seit 2 Tagen habe ich ganz starke Schmerzen im Bein.
Sogar in Ruhe, meinen Sie?
Ja, auch in Ruhe.
Okay.
Also, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10,
wobei eines sehr leicht und sehr unerträgliche Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde sagen 6 bis 7.
6 bis 7?
Okay.
Das ist aber in Ruhe, ne?
Also Sie können...
In Ruhe.
Wenn ich mich jetzt bewege, ich wollte heute etwas in ein Treppel steigen.
Das schaffe ich nicht mehr.
Das tut dann noch so weh am Bein.
Also ich bleibe lieber in Ruhe sitzen im Sessel.
Okay.
Und diese, Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind bis in den Fuß.
Das ist eigentlich...
Ja, die strahlen eigentlich fast bis in den Fuß.
Also, besonders im Oberschenkel, aber auch im Unterschenkel.
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verschlimmert?
Bewegung verschlimmert.
Bewegung.
Okay.
Und was lindert, haben Sie nicht bemerkt?
Nein.
Nur Pause.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine offene Wunde oder etwas anderes am Bein?
Oder das ist nur Schmerzen?
Nein, nicht bekannt.
Ich habe mich da auch nicht verletzt oder so.
Ich bin auch nicht begeistert.
Ja, und?
Ja.
Und also bezüglich des Beins, haben Sie Blässehaut oder Haarausfall oder Rötungen, Schwellungen,
was bemerkt?
Also irgendwie fühlt sich das linke Bein etwas kälter an, kühler an als das rechte.
Mhm.
Kältergefühl und kriebeln oder taubheißgefühl auch vielleicht?
Ich so richtig.
Eher so kühl, dass es so kühl ist.
Okay.
Das ist aufgefallen.
Ja.
Okay, aber keine, keine, also keine dicke Beine.
Keine Schwellung.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Ja, also ansonsten haben Sie vielleicht Brustschmerzen bemerkt oder eine Atemnut?
Nein.
Das habe ich nicht.
Das haben Sie nicht.
Okay, fühlen Sie sich fieberig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Ihnen letzter Zeit Abo dazu genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ich muss aufpassen.
Ich habe so einen guten Appetit, dass ich ihn nicht noch zunehme.
Also ich wiege hier schon 86 kg und ja, aber zur Unumhabung habe ich nicht.
Ja, schon.
Also schlafen Sie gut?
Normal gut, aber jetzt seit zwei Nächten mit den Schmerzen habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang alle ein bis zwei Tage.
Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Verstopfung, aber das kenne ich.
Muss ich aufpassen, wenn ich Schokolade esse oder so, das ist nicht gut.
Das ist auch nicht gut wegen meinem Zucker.
Und Wasserlassen in der Nacht muss ich zweimal gehen.
Ich bin vor zwei Jahren an der Prostata operiert worden.
Und zweimal muss ich zur Toilette.
Kann danach aber wieder gut einschlafen.
Okay, gut.
Und diese Prostata-Operation, wann wurde das durchgeführt?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Da war ein Prostata Krebs.
Und da wurde ich operiert und anschließend bestrahlt.
Okay.
Oper und Strahlung haben Sie gehabt.
Ja, schön.
Also haben Sie, wurden Sie noch andere oder wurde bei Ihnen noch andere
Operationen durchgeführt?
Altkind wurde ich operiert am Leistenbruch.
Auf der rechten Seite hatte ich ein Leistenbruch.
Da war ich, glaube ich, so zehn Jahre alt.
Und dann hatte ich noch einen Bruch des rechten Unterarmes.
Beim damals habe ich noch Fußball gespielt.
Da musste auch eine Metallplatte in den rechten Unterarm
eingebaut werden.
Metallplatte.
Okay.
Und das war vor, wann wurde das gemacht?
Das war jetzt vor mindestens 30 Jahren.
Vor 30 Jahren.
Ja.
Und sind bei Ihnen vor Erkrankungen bemerkt, die Zuckerkrankheiten?
Ja, ich habe Zucker.
Seit drei Jahren nehme ich Zuckertabletten.
Und ich habe Harnsäure, habe ich erhöht
und hatte auch schon mal einen Gichtanfall vor zwei Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch eine Tablette ein.
Gichtanfall vor zwei Jahren.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt, vor zwei Jahren auch diese Prostata-Krebs.
Genau, das habe ich notiert.
Noch andere Vorerkrankungen dabei?
Nein.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme einmal für den Zucker Med-Formin.
Da hinter steht 850.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens und eine Tablette abends.
Okay.
Was noch?
Da nehme ich noch, damit die Harnsäure gesenkt,
nehme ich noch Alu-Purinol.
Und da hinter steht 300.
Okay.
Da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Nein.
Gut.
Ist bei Ihnen allergie bekannt?
Nein, ich kenne allergin habe ich nicht.
Allergie nicht.
Unverträglichkeiten beim Essen.
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, nicht rauchen.
Schon ziemlich lange, schon mindestens 40 Jahre.
Und da rauche ich jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Täglich.
Okay, das ist eigentlich viel.
20 Zigaretten, meine sehr geehrten Damen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, abends trinke ich gerne so zum Abendessen
eine Flasche Bier.
Also 1-2 Flaschen Bier trinke ich pro Tag.
Okay.
Also meine nächste Frage,
nehme Sie, denn ich persönlich, das ist eine rotinmäßige Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drohnen oder hatten Sie früher?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Gut, also kein Kontakt.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Und haben Sie auch Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter.
Die ist 35 Jahre alt, soweit ich aber weiß, die ist gesund.
Die wohnt nicht mehr bei uns.
Ja, alles gut.
Und Ihre Eltern, leben Sie noch?
Meine Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt, die lebt noch.
Die hat Maubblick Probleme mit einem schwachen Herzmuskel.
Herzmuskelschwäche, da bekommt sie einige Medikamente.
Und sie hatte vor 30 Jahren, hatte sie Brustkrebs.
Wurde operiert und auch bestrahlt.
Aber das ist gut verlaufen.
Und Ihr Vater?
Der Vater ist mir 72 Jahre verstorben.
Der hatte eine Schmerz-Krise,
eine Erweiterung der Bauchschlachtader.
Und da ist es geplatzt.
Ja, mein Ballett, also das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Ja.
Ich habe auch eine Schmerz-Krise,
aber ich habe auch eine Schmerz-Krise.
Ich habe auch eine Schmerz-Krise.
Schau mal, du wirst mal.
Noch eine wichtige Erkrankung bei Ihrer Familie
ist nicht bekannt, ne?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder,
der ist 65 Jahre alt, der hat auch Zucker.
Und der hat in beiden Beinen
ziemlich schwere Durchblutungsstörungen.
Und da wurde er auch schon mal mit einem Katheter behandelt.
Um die Beine zu sehen,
um die Blutgefäße wieder zu öffnen.
Das war wohl ganz gut, ganz erfolgreich.
Ja, schon.
Also mit Katheter untersuchen.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Bis zu meiner Prostataerkrankung war ich Zimmermann.
Und als ich dann den Prostata krank,
war ich dann wieder in der Brüder.
Und als ich dann den Prostata-Krebs bekam
und operiert wurde und bestrahlt wurde,
da bin ich dann in Rente gegangen.
Was macht einen Zimmermann?
Ein Zimmermann, der baut zum Beispiel
Dächer auf dem Haus, das Hausdach aus Holz.
Da kommen dann die Dachfannen drauf.
Das braucht der Zimmermann.
Ja, schön. Das ist auch ein Nachname.
Ja, Zimmermann ist auch ein Nachname, das stimmt.
Ja, so weit sind wir mit der, das Gespräch durch.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Ich habe ja noch nie solche Schmerzen gehabt.
Ja, eigentlich, ich habe schon eine Verdachtdiagnose,
aber vor der Untersuchung wäre das nicht so gut zu sagen.
Zuerst würde ich sie körperlich untersuchen
und ein paar Mal nach der Prostata-Krebs.
Dann können wir genau das besprechen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit,
die Patientensprache zu übersetzen
in die Fachsprache.
Und wenn Kollegen und Kolleginnen Fragen haben,
Gänzungen haben, vielleicht bitte stellen Sie die Fragen jetzt.
Dann können Sie das besprechen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, vielleicht bitte stellen Sie die Fragen jetzt
oder Kommentare.
Ja, also, nur eine Frage möchte ich noch fragen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit, oder sind Sie in letzter Zeit gereist?
Seitdem ich diese Krebserkrankung habe,
Prostata-Krebs, verreisen wir nicht mehr groß.
Wir sind, vereisen in Deutschland.
Wir waren mal, für eine Woche,
waren wir mal in Frankreich.
Aber sonst verreisen wir nur innerhalb Deutschlands noch.
Okay.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut.
Ja, haben Kollegen noch Ergänzungen oder Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte.
Schreibt uns die Sport.
Ich habe früher Fußball gespielt, aber in den letzten Jahren habe ich keinen Sport mehr gemacht.
Da bin ich so bequem geworden.
Der Beruf ist auch so anstrengend als Zimmermann gewesen.
Da war ich abends immer so müde und erschöpft.
Nein, Sport habe ich leider nicht mehr gemacht.
Ja, ne.
Was ist das?
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig zum Haushalts- und wissen Sie, wie hoch Ihre Blutzeit sind?
Also, ich gehe regelmäßig auch wegen dem Zucker zum Hausarzt.
Der macht alle Vierteljahre, bis der da diesen Zucker langzeitwert auch.
Und damit war der Haushalts eigentlich ganz zufrieden.
Er sagt immer nur, ich muss aufpassen, dass mein Gewicht nicht weiter steigt.
Am besten sogar etwas abnehmen.
Beim Urologen bin ich ja auch noch in der Nachkontrolle.
Da war ich das letzte Mal vor sechs Monaten.
Ich gehört vom Urologen so weit, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Seit sechs Monaten haben Sie weitere Probleme mit Knuchen oder Gelenk oder Lunge?
Nein, ich hatte nur seit einigen Wochen diese Beschwerden beim Gehen,
dass ich Beschwerden im Bein hatte.
Das habe ich seit einigen Wochen bemerkt.
Und jetzt eben heftige Schmerzen seit zwei Tagen.
Aber sonst hatte ich vorher keine Probleme.
Okay, haben Sie früher einheblich werden?
Zum Beispiel, während langer Zeit laufen?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Können Sie das noch mal wiederholen?
Haben Sie früher einheblich werden, besonders bei Belastung?
Nein, habe ich vorher so noch nicht gehabt.
Ersten Mal haben Sie.
Nee, habe ich noch nie gehabt so.
Vielen Dank.
Vielleicht zum Schmerzcharakter.
Der Schmerz ist eher dumpf.
Es ist ein dumpfer, bohrender Schmerz.
Da gibt es eine Frage, sehe ich hier unten.
Vor einigen Wochen konnte ich 150 bis 200 Meter gut gehen.
Seit einigen Wochen ist es eben schlechter geworden.
Aber jetzt zur Zeit mit den akuten Schmerzen kann ich gar nicht mehr groß gehen.
Da bleibe ich lieber im Sessel sitzen.
Da habe ich gar nicht probiert, längere Strecken zu gehen.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Ich habe manchmal Rückenschmerzen, aber nicht besonders stark.
Besondere Rückenschmerzen.
Nein, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Viel stärker sind die Beinschmerzen.
Ja, also ich bin bereit, aber ich bin nicht so sehr gut mit Fachbegriffen immer.
Aber ich versuche das.
Können wir ja üben?
Ja, ich habe jetzt vielleicht innerhalb von zwei Monaten einen Termin für die Prüfung.
Das ist aber genauer, ist das nicht bekannt.
Ich werde einen Brief bekommen, dann in zwei Wochen würde ich den Termin haben.
Sie können es ja versuchen.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt, ich hatte einen Patienten.
Hatten Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Es geht um Herr Walter Kaufmann, 64 Jahre Patient, geboren am 26. März 1961.
1,63 m groß.
1,83 m.
1,83 m, habe ich geschrieben eigentlich.
1,83 m groß und 86 kg schwer.
Sie städte sich bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestehender dumpfer und bohrenden Schmerzen
im linken Oberschenkel mit Ausstrahlung in den Fuß.
Die Schmerzen sind schon seit Langem bei ihm bekannt.
Er könnte bis 150, 200 Meter laufen.
Dann sollte er eine Pause machen, aber jetzt hat er sogar in Ruhe diese Schmerzen.
Sie sagen, die Schmerzen sind schon seit Langem bekannt.
Können Sie etwas nennen?
Ja, das habe ich nicht gefragt.
Der Patient hat gesagt seit einigen Wochen, seit einigen Wochen.
Er hat seit vier Wochen bemerkt, dass er beim Gehen Schmerzen im linken Bein hat.
Er muss dann stoppen.
Sie können auch sagen, der Patient stellt sich wegen Akute seit zwei Tagen bestehender Schmerzen
im linken Oberschenkel mit Ausstrahlung ins linken Unterschenkel und Fuß.
Der Schmerz wird als dumpf und bohrend beschrieben.
Er verstärkt sich bei Bewegung vor sechs bis sieben.
Seit einigen Wochen berichtet der Patient von belastungsabhängigen Schmerzen im linken Bein
nach einer Gestrecke von 150 bis 200 Metern.
Man kann sagen, es bestehen belastungsabhängige Schmerzen seit einigen Wochen in den linken Bein.
Ist der Patient irgendwie gestürzt? Hat er einen Unfall gehabt?
Dann habe ich auch nicht gefragt.
Der Patient hat kurz gesagt, ich bin nicht gestürzt oder hatte keinen Unfall.
Es sollten Sie immer fragen nach einem Unfallereignis.
Das kann sein, dass der Patient plötzlich sagt, ich bin ja vor je Woche von der Leiter gefallen.
Das war jetzt gar nicht so schlimm, aber jetzt kommt es vielleicht.
Aber es besteht kein Unfallereignis.
Hat der Patient sonst noch etwas beobachtet?
An der Haut war ein Schmerz.
Den Patienten ist ein kälter Gefühl aufgefallen.
Die Frage nach einer Schwellung, Rötung oder Haarausfall wurde verneint.
Die Vegetative an einem Näser war bis ins Omni.
Der Schmerzbedingte ins Omni seit zwei Tagen.
Und Obziptation unauffällig.
Er hat auch zweimal den nächtlichen Wasser lassen.
Das ist nach der Prostata-Operation, das vor zwei Jahren durchgeht.
Das nächtliche Wasser lassen.
Kennen Sie den Begriff nächtliches Wasserlassen?
Also Nüktorie.
Es besteht eine zweimalige Nüktorie.
Es ist wohl berichtet in diesem Zusammenhang von einer Prostata-Operation vor zwei Jahren.
Können Sie dann noch eigentlich bei den grönlichen Nachkorknungen?
Bei Ihnen sind noch diese folgende Operationen bekannt.
Als Kind mit zehn Jahren auf der linken Seite in Guinalhaneh-Operation wurde durchgeführt.
Vor 30 Jahren wurde im rechten Unterarm auch wegen einer Fraktur eine Operation durchgeführt.
Und mit Metallplatten habe ich auch gesehen.
Wahrscheinlich, man kann sagen eine Plattenostiosynthese.
Das ist die Angabe des Patienten.
Man müsste jetzt noch nachfragen, ist das Metall noch im Körper oder wurde das Metall nach einer gewissen Zeit entfernt?
Könnte man fragen.
Ist aber jetzt nicht so entscheidend.
Was hat der Patient für chronische Erkrankungen?
Für chronische Erkrankungen hat er Diabetes mellitus seit drei Jahren.
Er ist mit Formin 850mg zweimal täglich gut eingestellt.
Der Patient hat vor zwei Jahren auch einen Gichtanfall gehabt.
Deswegen nimmt er auch Allupquinol 300mg einmal täglich.
Kennen Sie die Ursache für einen Gichtanfall?
Welcher Wert im Blut ist dabei erhöht?
Genau, das ist Harnsäure.
Sagen Sie ruhig der Begriff, heißt Hyperurikemi.
Hyperurikemi, das ist die Harnsäure Erhöhung.
Viele Patienten haben eine Hyperurikemi und manche Patienten bekommen dann eine Artritis urika.
Das ist ein Gichtanfall.
Der Patient nimmt Allupurinol 300, haben Sie gesagt.
Dann war vorhin die Rede von einer Prostata-Operation.
Können Sie dazu Näheres sagen?
Ja, diese Prostata-Operation war wegen einer Prostata-Karsinom.
Er hat eine Operation und hat sogar danach Strahlung bekommen.
Kennen Sie den Begriff für Bestrahlung oder Radioterapie?
Ja, oder Radiatio.
Vor zwei Jahren Prostata-Karsinom mit OP und anschließender Radiatio.
Gab es Auffälligkeiten in der Nachsorge?
Was ich mich erinnere, dass er die Sennüb-Nyctore danach bekommt.
Ist der Patient noch ein regelmäßiger Nachsorge?
Ja, aber das haben die anderen Kollegen gefragt.
Vor sechs Monaten war die letzte Nachsorge und die war nach Auskunft des Patienten unauffällig.
Das stimmt.
Nach einer Karsinom, das ist wichtig.
Hat der Patient sonst die persönliche Risikofaktoren?
Außerdem Diabetes Melitus, Hyperurikämie.
Er ist Raucher seit 40 Jahren und mit 40 Parkumtschere.
40 Packages, ruhig auf Englisch.
Es besteht ein erheblicher Nikotin ab Usus von 40 Packages.
Das ist eine erhebliche Menge.
Man kann das Wort Nikotin ab Usus sagen.
Er trinkt auch abends ein, zwei Flaschenbier.
Täglich Drogenkursum wurde verneint.
An Familien an Amnesien sind auch bezüglich dieses Falls auch beim Vater.
Er ist wahrscheinlich an einem Arten-Dyssektion verstorben mit 72 Jahren.
Der Vater ist mit 72 Jahren an einer Arten-Ruptur verstorben.
Das wissen wir nicht.
Es besteht zumindest in der Familie eine gewisse Gefäßvorbelastung.
Die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Leider hat sie Herzinsuffizienz.
Vor 30 Jahren wurde sie wegen einer Brustkarzinom.
Sie haben sich mit einer Brustkarzinom operiert.
Was gibt es Geschwister?
Der Bruder ist 65 Jahre alt.
Er leidet auch an Diabetes-Militus.
Er leidet auch unter Blutungsstörungen an den Beinen.
Bei ihm wurde eine Geografie durchgeführt.
Wahrscheinlich besteht bei dem Bruder eine PAVK.
Eine PAVK, eine pfiatäre Verstichkrankheit.
Eine pfiatäre Verstichkrankheit.
Er ist seit zwei Jahren verheiratet.
Er ist in Rente gegangen.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau und seiner Tochter.
Er ist
Diagnostisch kommen tiefen Wenenthrombose, vielleicht erisipäel.
Hat der Patient Fieber?
Eigentlich nicht.
Und tief für Beinwienenthrombose wurde da schon mal beschrieben im Chat.
Ja, in der Regel macht das eine Schwellung im Bein.
Genau, ja.
Was gäbe den noch in Betracht?
Denken Sie mal an die nähere Vorgeschichte des Patienten.
Was war vor zwei Jahren?
Also, vor zwei Jahren war diese eigentlich Prostata-Operation,
aber bezüglich der Operation, könnte Lenfürdämmer sein?
Das hat er auch.
Könnte es eine Ossere metastase sein im Oberschenkel?
Ja, also kann sein.
Man muss es zumindest in Betracht ziehen.
Also, es besteht einmal der vorhochgradige Vertracht auf einen Gefäßverschluss,
wahrscheinlich im Oberschenkelbereich, in der Arteia femoralis vielleicht.
Dieser akute Schmerz oder heftige Schmerz, der jetzt eingetreten ist,
die Haut ist kühl, sagt der Patient, vielleicht ist die Haut sogar sehr kalt.
Ob man periphere Pulse tasten kann, wird die Untersuchung zeigen.
Also, es besteht der hochgradige Verdacht auf eine Gefäßerkrankung.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber ich würde differenzial diagnostisch auch an das Prostata-Kazinom denken.
Es gibt leider immer wieder auch Fälle von Osseren metastasen beim Prostata-Kazinom,
wo sechs Monate vorher in der Nachsorgeuntersuchung,
zumindest beim Urologen, alles gut war.
Dann muss man zumindest auch an die Vorgeschichte denken,
dass auf alle Fälle muss der Oberschenkel, muss es eine Bildgebung geben
und das genau anzuschauen, wo kann der Schmerz herkommen.
Und der Schmerz kann durchaus nach Peripher ausstrahlen
bei einer Osseren metastase.
Das kann durchaus sein.
Mehr spricht für eine artigale Verschlusskrankheit.
Der Patient berichtet über seit einigen Wochen bestehender
belastungsabhängiger eine Claudicatio-Symptomatik,
Claudicatio-Intermittence.
In Deutschland sagen wir dazu die Schaufensterkrankheit.
Der Patient geht von Schaufenster zu Schaufenster in den Städten
und er ist nicht neugierig, was in dem Fenster ist, in den Geschäften,
sondern er muss stehen bleiben, weil er Schmerzen hat.
Das heißt dann die Schaufensterkrankheit.
Also es ist eine Claudicatio-Intermittence-Symptomatik,
die der Patient hat seit einigen Wochen.
Und jetzt hat er wahrscheinlich einen Gefäßverschluss
oder einen Zugefäßverschluss, der ihm den Dauerschmerz bereitet.
Aber bitte differentialdiagnostisch,
das Prostatakazinom nicht vergessen.
Prostatakazinom, okay.
Irrezipil, würde ich eher sagen, da ist der Allgemeinzustand oft,
wenn es ein richtiges Irrezipil ist,
ist der Allgemeinzustand oft sehr stark beeinträchtig bei den Patienten.
Die Patienten haben in der Regel oder zumindest häufig Fieber.
Und sie berichten eher von einer warmen Haut oder geröteten Haut,
als vielleicht von einer kühlen Haut.
Genau, das merkt man eigentlich.
Ja, ja, ist klar.
Okay, ja, ja, aber ruhig einige Differentialdiagnosen nennen.
Es geht ja nicht um die richtige Diagnose,
sondern dass sie zumindest einige Gedanken äußern
und dafür dann auch sagen, differentialdiagnostisch
muss man auch ein Irrezipil ausschließen
oder eine tiefe Weinbähntompose ausschließen,
aber auch an das Prostatakazinom denken.
Ja, ne?
Gut, aber ich finde, das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie gut verstanden.
Denken Sie bitte immer wieder dran, in diesem Fall ist
Herr Kaufmann der Patient, eher, ne?
Eher.
Eine Patientin sagen Sie sie, ja?
Also maskulin-feminin.
Das wird gerne vertauscht.
Aber ich habe Sie gut verstanden
und Sie haben die allermeisten Fachbegriffe.
Es waren jetzt nicht so ganz viel heute,
aber die haben Sie gut übersetzt
und denken Sie nochmal, das fällt Ihnen ein.
An das nächtliche Wasserlassen, an die Nüktorie.
Ja?
Das Wasserlassen, da sagen Sie ruhig bezüglich der Niktion,
besteht eine zweimalige Nüktorie,
wahrscheinlich in Folge der Prostata-Operation.
Aber eine zweimalige Nüktorie ist, sagen wir mal,
bei Menschen ab 60 Jahren durchaus nicht atologisch,
sondern es tritt häufiger auf, je nachdem,
auf wie viel Trinkmenge abends zu sich genommen wird.
Mineralwasser, Bier, Tee, was auch immer.
Hängt ja davon schon ab.
Gut, ja, dann würde ich doch sagen,
üben Sie weiter Fachbegriffe.
Wenn Sie sagen, da sind Sie noch nicht so gut.
Wenn das der Schwerpunkt ist, habe ich aber ein gutes Gefühl,
dass Sie das gut hinkriegen.
Ja, dann wünsche ich Ihnen.
Dann wünsche ich allen eine gute Woche
und wir können uns wieder verabreden für nächsten Donnerstag.
Dann sage ich einmal Tschüss.